i don't cook i don't clean but let me
tell you i got this
ring it looks like cardi b is single but
apparently
not ready to mingle the rapper went live
on her only fans account wednesday night
to set the record straight
about her relationship status after
filing for divorce from her husband
offset
saying quote you cannot hurt my feelings
trying to throw the divorce in my face
because
at the end of the day i decided i wanted
to leave i didn't wait until he cheated
on me again
i didn't wait for another controversy
with him being involved
i decided to leave if i wanted to stay i
could have stayed
i decided to leave this sounds like
carter
this sounds like cardi with the braids
she added i could date any man i want my
dms are flooded
i don't actually want to date nobody i'm
so focused on my business that it's
crazy
this isn't the first time cardi has
claimed she is single by
choice i want to let y'all know i have
not shed now once here
you know every single time that you know
this guy have done
something so crazy so and it hits the
media i'm always crying i'm always
stressed out i'm sad because
i don't like that type of this time
i wasn't crying a few days after filing
for divorce she took to instagram to
explain
why she made the difficult decision i
just got tired of
arguing i got tired of not seeing things
eye to eye so before
when when you feel like it's just not
the same anymore
before you actually get cheated on i'd
rather just leave
aside from divorce drama cardi has her
hands full with her daughter
culture who now has her own instagram
account pick your swag
yeah you got swag girl where you got
your swag from
i like your outfit and of course she's
definitely been working hard on her
music in august she released the first
single off her new album
[ __ ] featuring megan the stallion now
from the top
make it drop that's some wet and cuz she
not get a [ __ ] in a mob
that's some wet and she
[Music]
in 2019 e.t caught up with cardi on what
we can expect from her new music
i can't really rap about the struggle i
can't really rap about
what i used to work um work on because
you know i passed the next level so
what am i gonna talk about besides the
glamour but i feel like i've been in a
lot of drama
i feel like people have thrown so many
things so many different crazy obstacles
a new chapter in my life that this is
like oh i got a whole lot of
to talk about there's a lot of things
that i don't be saying that it's like
you know what every single time that i
say it
people eat me up a lot from it they say
i complained so much i said you know
what i'm just gonna put it in my music
[Music]
then